my goal here is to make you guys as much
money as humanly possible if you're a
lazy mother you better have a load to
leverage now you have a $300 million
year exit rather than a $25 million year
he's like that sounds better here's
what's crazy he 10x the company he just
added $10 million to his net worth so
we're going to start with a little
exercise I'm going to call it the magic
wand all right so right now if I have a
magic wand or you have a magic wand and
you wave it and you get to make as much
money as you want all right so write
down or put at least think about it in
your head what number that would be per
month okay how much money are you making
per
month okay hopefully it doesn't take too
long to think of a
number now who here currently is making
that amount of money please raise your
hand wonderful so we have just done is
established a gap between where you are
and where you'd like to go fantastic so
here's
you here's goal which we all just
established
now in scenario one you have these goals
right and there's all of these different
ways of getting there right and the
problem is you're like which one do I do
before I explain more on that scenario
two is I don't know what to do to get to
there let me tell you how these feel
this one feels like
anxiety so
if you feel stressed or you are
overwhelmed about which thing you should
do that's
this if you don't know what to do you're
at a loss you feel hopeless because
you're like I don't know what the [__]
to do like I don't know I don't know
what to do and it's not about picking
it's like you don't even know where to
start and this has been really important
for me to identify if I feel anxiety
it's because I don't know which thing to
pick if I'm feeling sad it's because I
feel hopeless I'm like okay hopelessness
means I have a lack of choices so I have
a lack of choices means I I have
ignorance around this topic okay this
makes it solvable so then I can start
solving for I need a path so that I know
what to do it's the only thing I know me
personally that's what makes me sad is
if I don't know what to do I get sad is
this resonating with anyone here okay so
when you're deciding which thing to
do this is a clear case of lack of
strategy all right now strategy is a big
fluffy amorphous word that gets tossed
around a lot and no one knows what the
[__] it means but it's probably
important and in my opinion is the most
important but I'm going to give you a
different definition for this to make it
a little bit more useful
okay strategy is just
prioritizing it's all it is like
whenever you hear someone say we have to
figure out our strategy it just means we
have to figure out our priorities it's
all it me
and in layman's terms it's what's going
to get us the most bang for the buck if
you want the fancy definition that I
have it's how you choose to allocate
resources that are limited against
unlimited
options that is strategy and the tough
part about this about strategy in
general is that when you're
looking here you have all these
options
strategy is figuring out actually
there's one that's right
here that takes us off the page cuz the
most costly thing in business isn't just
the unknowns but it's the unknown
unknowns as in the things that you
didn't even know you could pick from I
show this to say that right now if my
goal here is to make you guys as much
money as humanly possible by the time I
am done my 46
minutes then if I can just get you to
make the one chest move that will make
you the most money then it will Roi
everything you do this year or maybe the
next five
years because fundamentally people don't
actually move faster than other people
like you see me walk it's not like I'm
hyperactive it's just you get more for
each step when you are more strategic
when you have better priorities and you
allocate your resources time money
energy into the fewest moves that get
you the most bang for the buck you make
the most
money so back to
this you guys want to hear a different
example so we had a we have a our
company that we bought we dove into the
data and it looked like 85% of the
businesses turned out within 2 or 3
months which is
horrendous 15% of the customers paid the
most and stayed the longest and they
were different I was like wild idea what
if we stop selling these 85% and only
sell these 15 and cater our stuff to
only them and he was like that would
kill my business mind you recurring
theme of the first one when I told him
to shut his agency down he had to go to
zero and then built the next thing and
for 9 months he was basically at zero is
hard like tough very simple to say very
hard to do could you guys imagine if you
have two locations I was like hey I can
help you get there for a year you're
going to have to make no money
cool what do you do play long game right
and he was willing to do that and that
was me talking to him off the cliff
every week being like hey man we're
going to get
there and so with this individual uh
with the pr we he cut 85% we catered the
messaging and we made it way more Niche
down to this specific Avatar and we 10x
the price and now we sell more units
than we did before we 10x the
company strategy rather than thinking
okay what am I going to do to just get
more now there's always a time for more
believe me violence is the answer big
fan all right of brutal Relentless
effort but we want to make sure that
we're capturing the most per unit of
effort and
so the equation for this
is volume time leverage equals output
which means the more times you do
something and the more the more you get
for each time you do it the more you get
ultimately now if you're a lazy
[__] guess what you better have
a shitload of
Leverage no you can be lazy and still
make tons of money you just have to have
lots of Leverage you got to be really
strategic in the moves you make the more
activity you have the more you can let a
little bit of that uh
violence um work for you but it ends up
becoming a cap soon enough because at
the end of the day we only have X amount
of hours and if you want to do big [__]
you need a lot of other people's hours
to work for you which is a form of
Leverage I'll give you a third one so we
had a a company that uh is an
association of of uh trying to keep it
vague let's call dentists Association of
dentists they had a they had a business
that like they' glob all the savings
together of all the dentists said that
they would charge less than all of them
saved with with the conglomerate of
buying power right so if you save
$30,000 a year as a dentist they would
charge 10 super sticky model great
business and so he's like hey I think I
could sell this thing for 20 or 30
million and uh I was like how many
dentists do you have there he's like I
don't know 500 I was like and they all
run the same systems I like yeah it's
like what's the average dentist make
like per unit it's like I don't know
500,000 I was
like wild
idea what if we take 10 every year
bundle them up and sell them from 100
million every
year get 20% give 80% to them that'd be
chill right I was like then you get your
exit every single year and then if you
want to sell it we exit the machine that
does rollups because then that you have
rollup machine does 20 or 30 million a
year in profit and we get 10x on that
now you have a 300 million year exit
rather than a $25 million year he was
like that sounds better I was like I'm
with you I
agree
strategy prioritizing what move will get
me the most for the effort I put in all
right now this is a perfect transition
to you're like okay that sounds very pie
in the sky
so next Tik Tok theory of constraint so
everything that we do at acquisition.
comom and the approach that we have with
growing any business is spending a lot
of effort to try and identify the
constraint of the business because every
single business is constrainted there is
one thing that is limiting its growth so
right now and here's the [__] up
part many of who here works all the
hours of the day like most of the hours
that you're
awake okay half of
you if your business is not growing as
fast as you want it to you are working
on the wrong
stuff if it has stayed the same and you
were spending all your time working on
it
you're not going to get more hours so
you're doing the wrong [__] so it means
that you have not properly identified
the constraint of the business
so I'll give you an example of this we
had a media company that came to us big
YouTubers 40 million plus subscribers
and they were like hey I was like what's
the goal they're like we want to make
money I like cool love it great goal
so they're like we think that we need to
create a better media machine it's like
okay okay they're like we need to really
systematize this and do it better it's
like okay how are you monetizing AdSense
by the way very inefficient way to
monetize okay and so they're like I
think we're I think this is these are
all the things we need to do to
eliminate our constraint for our
production
cool it's like have you thought of wild
idea maybe we just like the constraint
of the business is that you don't have
something to sell I was like you're like
a 97 out of a 100 on media and you're a
zero out of 100 on [__] to
sell and you're trying to talk about how
to get to a 99 rather than like if we
just went from 0 to 20 we would probably
make you 10 times more money than you're
currently making and so that is an idea
of the theory of the constraint right
like the constraint of that business was
not media and many of you the constraint
of your business is not making better
[__]
workouts
right that's not the constraint it's not
the constraint right that's not the
constraint and so right now if you spend
all your day working on [__] that
doesn't move the
ball working on the wrong [__] so let me
tell you how we do it so that hopefully
you can too so one of the questions I
like to ask is why can't we 10x this
business like why can't we and sometimes
asking that question and then it becomes
really apparent what the problem is and
the answer is sometimes well we just
need to hire all these people it's like
well let's [__] do that right and so
here's how we transition into the
tactics around
this so this is the actual first part of
my planning process prioritizing process
strategy process whatever shoe fits you
for figuring out what we're going to do
with a company that we're going to grow
so when we're thinking about all the
objectives all the things we could ually
do it has to map to one of these three
objectives which is one how is this
thing that we're going to spend time
money effort on going to get us more
customers two how is this thing going
that we're going to spend time money and
effort on get us increased LTG make them
worth
more or three how is the time energy Etc
going to decrease the risk that this
does not continue to happen in the
future which is another way of
translating how do we increase the
Enterprise Value overall so for example
if you do all of this stuff that's great
still really risky because if you die
the business dies now if we have to hire
someone to do the same thing as you is
it going to get more of either of these
probably not will it make the thing more
valuable absolutely does that make sense
so I'm going to segue briefly we're
going to side
quest imagine two
people 5 million Topline 5 million topl
line
2 million in bottom line 2 million in
bottom line this guy is a single owner
runs every all the day to day has lots
of minions known with real brains and
they just do what he says okay if this
person dies the business
dies this guy has a team that runs the
whole thing and he makes $2 million in
income from the business but it doesn't
require
him who's
richer thisy guy question is how much
richer a lot this guy because he doesn't
have to do anything means that somebody
else could also not have to do anything
and also collect that $2 million a year
which means his thing is probably worth
depending on what type of industry it's
in 10 15 sometimes $20
million and so when this guy here's
where the leverage comes in Big L if you
go from 2 million a year to 3 million a
year in income he just added $10 million
to his net worth this guy is concerned
about all of the tax evasion strategies
because he's trying to maximize income
and forgetting the fact that the asset
is the thing that's going to build us
net
worth this took me a really long time to
learn like an absurdly long time
everything I did was all about like how
do I take the income I have be more
efficient with it blah blah blah blah
blah when it's really like you become
wealthy from the [__] you own not the
[__] you
do so everybody here has a business and
right now many of the businesses in this
room are not valuable no one would buy
them because it's really just you with
some
helpers and so the IDE is that we have
to transition and this is a skill that
is worth getting because no matter what
you do for the rest of your
entrepreneurial career you're going to
need people you need to have the skill
of hiring recruiting training onboarding
managing Talent who here has one amazing
Superstar person who works for
you cool imagine if you had four of them
at your one location how easy would life
be right you make a ton of money here's
what's [__] crazy the difference
between small businesses and big
businesses is how many a players they
have and so what happens is most small
business owners hire a lot of people get
lucky one sticks actually works their
ass off at a fair rate and you're like
ah man if I had six more sandras right
I'd be good to go the thing is is that
big business owners maintain a higher
level or a lower tolerance for
mediocrity and so they actually do keep
looking until they find six Andreas and
then it does become too easy for for
them to kill it because I got six aners
how could I
lose that's the idea make sense okay
this took me a long time to learn like I
would just put up with people who are
mediocre and right now many of you have
a think of somebody who's mediocre on
your team actually I'll make it easier
think about that person that you thought
about today who you shouldn't have
thought about because if they're not
making you money and you're not sleeping
with them don't think about them first
thing in the morning all right
so anybody have somebody in
mind so if you have that person in mind
that person is taking up 25% of your
bandwidth what a cost right and probably
many of you the biggest lever of growth
is on the other side of a few heart
conversations I now talk to portfolio
CEOs all the time and it is incredibly
clear the people who will win and the
people who will not is simply based on
their ability to confront
discomfort and it's interesting because
as a mostly H it's kind of 50-50
actually audience U between male and
female but a lot of guys beat their
chest I can cold plunge I can run a long
time without stopping lift lots of
weight but you can't just say hey man I
think you suck a little
bit real can't do it and for that reason
they suffer for [__] decades because
they can't fire Sarah not Sandra
Sandra's stud right can't fire Sarah
it's like yeah I know she slept with one
of the clients but like I mean I think
her heart's in the right place it's like
whenever you're whenever you're
qualifying that someone's heart's in the
right place and deep down they're a good
person it's because it's obvious they
suck
right hit a nerve on that one
um so right now do me a favor write down
the name of the person that you know you
need to get back to and start what we
call a performance Improvement plan
which is you got 14 days to fix your
[__] or get
out and many of you can't even have the
conversation because you're too much of
a [__]
pansy real
talk and this will keep you
poor
seriously like you H like you got to
grow up got to be able to have hard
conversations be like
hey my biggest my biggest piece of
advice for this is you know the [__] you
say about Sarah while you're here behind
Sarah's back God she's just like she's
been slipping lately you know what I
mean like she's not shown up on time
she's not cleaning up after the classes
she's short with the with the clients I
two people complain about her right say
that to
her that's it just think about what you
[__] talk and just say it to
them it's just the truth just say it to
him see what
happens one of two things either they're
like [__] I've had my head up my ass
that's why it's been so dark
um
right you're totally right thank you
pull it out right and all of a sudden
they have a total 180 that happens like
one out of five times four out of five
times you say these are the things that
you have to do they either say I won't
do that or they say sure I'll try and we
both know they're not going to and then
you elegantly exit them from the
business the problem is that right now
Sarah teaches like six classes
[__] now what got to find somebody
else she's killing your business so get
rid of Sarah all right so that was a
side quest but hopefully we found some
treasure there and uh write the name of
the person you need to have that hard
conversation with and be like there's
this [__] speech and this guy I was
talking [__] about you and I should have
talk to your face and so this is me
talking [__] to your face so that I feel
better about it you kind of suck
okay thank
[Music]
[Applause]
you so right now there's a lot of [__]
that you guys probably learned so far
you're going to learn tomorrow and the
rest of the day
Etc if it doesn't do one of these three
things toss it number one number two you
might only be able to do one of them or
two of them and so then you got to pick
okay of all of these things which of
these has the highest likelihood of
working with the least amount of effort
you do that one first and as silly as
this sounds many of you won't do this
and the reason I say this is because I
talk to people we making a million a
month a million a week and they
sometimes forget too so like when you
have the same conversation over and over
again you you start to develop
Frameworks around it right and the first
framework that I wanted to give you
around strategy is how does this get us
more customers how does this make them
worth more and how does this increase
the likely that those two first things
don't stop happening if it doesn't map
to that forget about it just cut it
because there are other things that will
do that that we should be doing
instead cool
now the second framework is going to go
one level down
what who how so usually when you do this
whole thing you get a big list of whats
right these are all the things I got to
do what what what what what what what
you're like [__] there's a lot of
whats who's going to do it most the time
you're like
me
right the difference between the guys
who become bigger business owners and
the ones who don't is they have to think
how can I get my team to do this for me
now this is not a team team talk but I
am telling you that the reason the gym
launch went from 3 million a year or
whatever it was to 37 and still cranks
um was because of Lila because I was
like we're going to make it the Alex
show she's like that's a terrible idea
um and so she built a team and started
empowering the team she's like you can't
do that she started taking things off my
calendar I was like hey I like that
she's like no not for you that's for
Sandra look I got six sandras they all
want to
work and so what ended up happening is
has anyone given a task to someone on
your team and they actually just did a
great job with it and you're like oh
thank God that was awesome anyone had
that happen Okay so big businesses do
that all the time and you just do it
lots of sandas and if you can't give
[__] to any Sandra then you're the
problem because you have really low
standards and you're a
[__] you can't have hard convos it's
what it is like literally it comes down
to that big Macho guys can't tell the
female trainer that she
sucks can't do
it can't do
it and so what happens is we have this
big list of whats and then we put
Santana on the first two and we're like
but man it'd be cool if we could do some
of these other
ones who should we give it to and then
we start assigning the hoop
but here's a fun trick if you've given
the same who the same thing 12 weeks in
a row like each quarter and the what's
not done the who's the
problem winners win and I'm sure that
the best people that you have on your
team hit the ground running started
taking [__] off your plate immediately
started executing everybody loved them
remember what that felt like that
blueprint is what talent looks like and
you just have to do more of that get
more of those people which then opens up
the next thing which is I'm not the type
of leader who will attract that type of
talent I don't have time to get into
fixing you right now but that is what
the next thing that happens is okay
fantastic so Tick Tock over for this
strategy session go to the next
one all right oh good I'm great I'm
crushing on time next framework for
[Applause]
you
more better new so as soon as we figure
out that we have the highest strategic
leverage activity that we can in a
business we then ask
ourselves can we just do
more why can't we do more I want to do
more
more money let's do that more more more
right or we say can we do it better we
don't have to invest any your resources
just do it better we're going to go from
calling leads in 30 minutes to calling
leads in under five deal
fantastic once we do all the mors and
all the betters then and only then do we
do new now here's how most small
business owners decide what they're
going to do oh here we go all
right
new and the thing is is a lot of you
guys are going to come back from here
with lots of new you're going to be like
hey team I'm going to vomit all over you
I'm going to make no plan it's going to
be awesome and they're just going to be
like let's give it a week he'll forget
about all the things he said and we'll
go back to normal real talk it's going
to
happen gym launch since we sold it to
whatever is years ago whatever the time
was
2021 I'm so proud of kale and the team
because they consistently ask thank you
um how can we do more of what we're
doing how can you do it better Jim wch
has grown 40% since Alex and Lila exited
the majority share we still own 30 plus%
of it
but and I think in a lot of ways Kale's
a better CEO than I am because I also
like new shiny things
too but kale is super disciplined he's
an exceptional CEO there's a lot to
learn from him how can I do more how can
I do it better so it's like hey dude I
think we should be getting on Tik Tok
he's like you know what we could also do
we [__] double our Co call team do
that what do we do that what's the
likelihood that if we double our Co call
team we'll make more sales
hi we already have a trotten path there
let's just do more of that but what
about Tik Tock it's like yeah likelihood
that we're going to get sales I don't
know we've never done it before I don't
know but what about this kid I saw on
the internet he's making
millions let's just double our cold C
team and then let's look at our better
and say like do you think we can clean
the numbers more do you think we can
improve the script do you think we can
follow up faster do you think we can
personalize the reach outs more
probably and so right
now this is real real the thing that is
killing most of you guys
is the desire to 10x in 90
days and then not doing it and trying
something new and hoping for a silver
bullet That Never Comes it's just it's
100 golden
BB's like the big businesses it's just
golden BB's it's just improving lots of
little things over and over again the
40% Improvement that Jim wch has had
since we sold our majority share has
there's been no one thing and man
wouldn't I love to make that short video
there isn't one thing we just improved a
lot of little things and that creat
Crees the big outcome and so right now
you probably have this big
list of should do like I should do that
I should probably email my list
sometime right at some point I should do
that right I should probably do more
cold DMS or do more reach outs I should
probably make more ads to run I should
probably do that I should probably
figure out our pricing and optimize it I
should probably create that sales
training program or get my team to go
through that sales training program I
should probably set up a roleplaying
Cadence for my team so they sell
better but you know what's
new that sounds cool the should do if
you actually just wrote all the things
that you need to do down and then you
tick them off and you realize that it
takes two years to build an exceptional
business and you did nothing but just
actually do all the [__] you know you
should be doing you usually build a
pretty exceptional
business it's the rush that kills
everyone it's the hope that this new
thing is somehow going to shortcut the
work that needs to be
done and like this has just been true
and true because the thing is is that
that list for a $10 million company is
longer and bigger that list for a $100
million company is longer and bigger and
it's just [__] that needs to get done
and so the faster you can confront the
work that has to get done the faster you
start getting the getting getting to the
getting there you go is this making
sense all right thanks man appreciate
it all right
now you're going to have a lot of
different
things you're going to have a lot of
different things that uh that you could
do right and you've noticed this is the
central theme is like you've got a lot
of decisions to make and I just want you
to make the right one I want you to make
the one that makes the most bang for the
buck and an easy way to order
this is
impact ease there we
go so when you have your big list of
[__] just put it as
one 2 3 four just put a number next to
it really
easy lots of impact really easy do these
first
then once you've done all of
those hey don't consume any more
information once you've done wait but I
I haven't once you do all of these then
start working on
these then start working on these then
[__]
these I really want to Rebrand the
logo why no one knows that you exist to
begin with what are we talking about
you're like I want to Rebrand it's like
why like you have a nameless ass no one
has any association with your first
thing like Xerox is just made up letters
right they created a brand because
branding is the consistent action of
associating the unknown with the known
right it's I know I'm supposed to talk
about social media branding I didn't
think it was going to be super important
for you guys uh because you don't need
to for now in my
opinion not because it wouldn't benefit
you but because there are other things
that I think would benefit you more just
to be clear okay
now I'm going to give you this little uh
this little TI raade and then I may I
may have time but I may not have time at
the end for Q&A we'll see
so often times the things that is
limiting the business is the big obvious
thing so we have really big egos about
our business we assume that it's
exceptional we assume that it's
excellent
right but in your heart of hearts you
probably know that if you were actually
[__] exceptional you would not be
asking questions about how to get more
leads because You' have people referring
their friends and referrals by the way
are nonlinear in that they are
exponential in nature two bring four
four bring eight Etc so the book the
$100 million offers book was probably my
first big experience with that because I
spent like a very long time writing it
and then I gave it away for 99 and I
made one post and I think this when I
had like 20,000 Instagram followers in
total and I didn't have really any other
platforms and that book to this day
sells more copies every month than it
did the month before and like last month
it sold 25,000 copies it's like almost a
thousand books a day a thousand
customers every day no marketing spend
just word of mouth right and 14,000 F
stars and so like it's the big obvious
thing and from being in the room with
Millionaires and sorry billionaires and
decad billionaires the thing that has
become so clear to me is that the people
who are obsessed with their product are
the ones that get the compounding and so
every business needs to have some sort
of compounding vehicle within it
otherwise you're going to spend the rest
of your life trying to promote it so
think about this way if I spend two
years trying to write a book and at the
end of the two years it's
exceptional I'm going to give the
alternative example first if I spend two
months writing a book and I publish it
and I have to spend the rest of my life
trying to promote it to get people to
buy it it's a tough life low leverage on
the flip side if I spent two years
trying to build something [__]
incredible and then let my customers
Market it for me for the rest of my life
more work upfront less work long term
it's just that being willing to delay
satisfaction or gratification is in my
opinion the single greatest skill that
you can develop and what's Wild is that
a lot of you guys think you have that
skill you only do when it comes to
cookies but not when it comes to
money and so you like give your clients
all these lectures about self-discipline
and being hard and like you know
believing in your better self but like
you will take actions that are in direct
contradiction that same thing it's just
we're switching calories for dollars
same thing and so when I see a lot of
the B like the gym owners that struggle
it's just the big obvious thing the
sandwich sucks they're like dude what's
the new marketing thing for like gyms
I'm like have you tried your sandwiches
they are
terrible why would you want more people
to
know right like it's it's it's real
though right like imagine I had a
mediocre book which is what most people
would have and then I spent tons of
money trying to Market it why would I do
that it sounds ridiculous when you think
about it you're like I'm just going to
let everyone know I'm mediocre that
would suck but that's what a lot of
people in this room do every day
and so the thing is is that in my
opinion if I were to start a gym over
today I would consistently work on the
actual product the experience the way
people get greeted the trainings for all
of the teams into the world's simplest
model and until people were not leaving
I would not be worried about bringing
more customers
in once you get that right then when
you're pouring all this gas in you can
catch it because if you got a hole out
the other side your
constraint is the fact that people don't
stay and so the biggest thing that you
have to solve for because now we we buy
into a lot of brick and mortar Chains
It's one of my favorites unsurprisingly
is LTV or lifetime gross profit over
everything the guys who can spend the
most money on marketing are the ones who
make the most money from ads so when you
see these massive marketing companies or
these massive campaigns that are out
there it's not because they're better at
marketing it's because their LTV enables
them to spend as much as humanly
possible in the marketing if you print
cash on the back end you can get silly
on the front
end this has to syn in like this has to
sync in and I keep being repetitive
about this because I continue to get the
same questions whenever I go and it's
like what's the new marketing trick
what's the new hack it's like you have
to solve the roote issue and it's kind
of like the uh it's like it's like the G
who's like hey is it keto is it
intermittent fasting is it you know like
I'm just trying to give the parallel
here like that's what you sound like you
don't get it you got to understand how
to count your Macros it is what it is
done and so like in the business it's
like you have to figure out how to get
the mouse trap to work even at its
simplest level so that people actually
like the thing you have and I just feel
like so many of the gyms that I see and
I go to it's obvious like takes 5
Seconds to see why they're not
successful and the gymm owner because
they're in it can't see it because their
ego their identity is attached to it
because you think that if your gym sucks
it means you suck and that's not true so
you have to break that you should be
like oh yeah we suck at that onboarding
non-existent churn through the
roof you should see my trainers slaving
each other it's
terrible Place absolute Pig St right so
what what's your Clan I'm going to
Market
it I'm going to Market
[Applause]
it
so to give a quick a quick uh re
recap and if I have time for Q&A I will
one brand is making associations between
things that are intangible with things
that are tangible and unknown so things
that people like if I hold a bunch of
bricks of gold on stage or I hold a
bunch of stacks of cash you will make
associations of money with me and if you
didn't know who I was you would assume
that I have something to do with money
that would be your assumption that would
be the association if I stand next to a
porn star you would assume other things
right associations and so if you want to
build a brand associate the service that
you have with the intangible ideas want
the prospect to believe about you so if
you want them to think that you are
clean and you are friendly and that you
care then start
there magic wand if you feel sad
immediately translate that into I do not
know what to do next it massively
simplifies this very like hard painful
experience it's been really helpful for
me so if you feel hopeless or you don't
know what to do it means you just don't
have options like you don't perceive
that you have options it's a lack of
options so you just have to become
informed all right so whenever I think
sadness I think ignorance it's like oh
that's solvable and then I can start
attacking it on the flip side if you
have lots of options and you feel
anxiety it's because you don't know how
to pick which means you have to
prioritize it means you have a lack of
strategy strategy is getting the most
bang for the buck it
is allocating finite resources against
infinite options and some of the biggest
strategic moves are outside the board
and that's where sometimes having gym
launch other people Etc is helpful
because you have outside eyes so your
mouth inch below your nose but you still
need somebody else to tell you a bad
breath I heard that the other day I
really liked
it right now There's a constraint in
your business if you do not know what
the constraint of your business is you
will not solve it you'll continue to do
the [__] you have been doing and that
has not been getting you what you want
so right now unless you change the
activities you do you will not change
the getting that you are
getting so if you go back so I'll give
you a different one
so intelligence and learning this will
be
fun so the definition of intelligence as
I Define it is rate of learning it's
it's a speed someone learns fast they're
smart someone learns slow they're a
little slow right rate of learning okay
what does learning
mean this is how you can remember
it same
condition new
Behavior which
means the phone rings and I trained you
and you answer it one way before I train
you and then I have the same condition
the phone rings again and then after I
trained you you behave differently you
have
learned if you come to this event and
you do things and then you leave this
event and you do the same things you
have learned
nothing which means that change in
behavior is the way that you can measure
intelligence the speed at which you
change
Behavior with within the same conditions
is your rate of learning the faster you
do that the smarter you are and so some
of y'all are hold on I got to figure out
the politic one uh
dumb but again when I Define words or
operationalize them it becomes a lot
more under my control so I'm like man I
don't want to be stupid it's like they
got to do this
thing I went to this marriage seminar
and they say that when my wife walks in
the door I should say something nice to
her damn right walks in the door you
went to the seminar and you're like nice
blouse she's like is that the top one or
the bottom one like I don't
know one of them right and so same
condition new Behavior it's also a great
way to teach your team which is like I'm
going to present this condition we're
going to train and when I present this
condition again I need you to change
your behavior that's what learning is
and so everybody here if you don't know
what to do then you're not going to be
able to change your behavior which means
you're not going to get different
outcome so
most of the success that I've had is my
effort to try and boil everything down
into an
inputs to outputs equation I remember
when I was studying for the GMAT back in
the day I found this research study that
showed that the number of problems that
you solved was in direct correlation
with the score you got on the test and I
was like oh yeah okay this is a clear
input output like life isn't always this
clean but I was like fantastic so I did
about a stack of phone books this High I
did four hours a day for 16 weeks of
problems and then I scored above a
Harvard Smith score I didn't start there
but I had the graph I was like the more
problems I do the higher my score is and
by the time I got to the actual test I
was like I've literally seen every one
of these problems before and I've done
all of them a 100 times right it's
became really easy and so if you don't
have the inputs outputs equation which
will be the last thing I do because kale
asked me to talk about
leads then you're not going to get there
all right so I'm going to give you guys
a sneak
peek you can write it down you can't
take pictures or talk about
it there's only eight ways to get
customers you got warm
Outreach you've got cold
Outreach got paid
ads got content
these are the only four things that you
can do so if you claim that you're
constraint because everything's amazing
about your gym and your trainers aren't
sleeping with each other and the Gym's
really clean and people don't churn and
you're priced appropriately and you have
really good onboarding experience and
people get reached out on a regular
basis to uh check in on them to show
that you actually give a [__] you do all
that stuff right and you think that your
constraint is more marketing which by
the way everyone thinks that's what it
is and if you keep thinking that nothing
changes is H may be wrong anyways let's
talk about leads so these are the only
four things you can do you can either
post content do warm reach outs do cold
reach outs or run pay
ads
simple I like to quantify this by the
rule of
100 which means you either spend 100
bucks a day on ads you do 100 cold
outreaches you do 100 warm outreaches or
you do 100 minutes of content you do it
every
day and if you want to get there faster
do more cu but you'll also get better
because you did more just like the
problems on the GMAT test if you're not
doing this
stuff what are you
doing you might be thinking about
marketing or advertising might be
strategizing planning you're not doing
any of it and the amount that you get
will be directly proportional to how
much of this stuff you do this is how
you let other people know about stuff
that's it that's all there is
now op is other people you've got your
customers who can refer you people
you've got Affiliates who can send you
people you've got employees who work for
you and then you've got
agencies those are the other four types
of people who can get you the
stuff if you think about it any of these
four do these on your behalf this by the
way is leverage if I can go get my
customers to tell everybody about my
book then I won't have to if I can get
Affiliates all the chiropractor places
in a five mile radius from my gym and
all the massage studios in a f mile radi
radius from my gym to just give a free
month with any new customer they have
because they know that I will treat them
right then I can just have 200 different
businesses that come to me now do those
200 businesses comeing out of the sky
nope what would you do warm reach outs
cold reach outs run ads or make content
targeting those people then they'd come
and then they do those things on your
behalf agency will do those things on
your behalf or if you do all that stuff
then you cold
Outreach cold Outreach warm Outreach
paid ads make content to get employees
and then the employees will do those
things on your behalf is this
simplifying some
[__] right now business can feel
confusing and usually it's because we
have not defined terms if you define the
terms then you can know what you're
actually talking about rather than like
making noise with your face okay if you
don't make noise with your face and just
know what you're talking about it
becomes a lot easier because the
variables become defined and so if you
want to get more leads you have to do
these things if you want to get even
more leads you get other people to do
these things for you which starts with
you doing these things to get those
people that's
it I have three
minutes
so I'm going to see if I missed anything
by the way giving away really good free
stuff great way to get more people to
opt into your
thing just in case anybody needed to be
convinced about doing free
stuff who here wants to look know what
it looks like when it's all the way
right yeah talk about scaling it okay so
this give you a little bit of vision for
the future so we love local Brands
they're great they're wonderful Capital
compounding Vehicles what you need to
know is how much does it cost to open a
facility all right cost to
open then you got to know your topl line
revenue or more specifically your bottom
line profit per facility the ratio
between these things let's say it's cost
me 100k to open a facility and let's say
I make 100K per year then I have a 100%
cash on cash return who here remembers
what the stock market is less than that
right which is why I like it
now this would not be that interesting
to me why because I know there's a lot
of operational drag associated with
opening facilties just make 100
grand
right and so the idea is how can I is
there a way that I can get a more
leverag model so I can make maybe like
250 to 500,000 per facility and then
maybe even if it cost me 500 to make
500 then I only have to open oneth as
many facilities in order to compound my
cash
now the way to do this and this is one
of the things that I've observed with
some of the most successful franchisers
in the space is you have your facility
now it has been your special child you
have lots of doodads and lots of
whizbangs that you've attached to it
specialized sessions blah blah blah BL
blah the franchise the franchises that
are the most
successful simplify it even if their
corporate or headquarters has like all
this stuff when they want to scale they
massively simplify they think how little
square footage can I possibly use
because I'm not using this to F fill my
ego I'm using it to fill my bank account
big
difference how little can I make this so
that I'm really efficient with capital
and then how can I make it as little
operational drag as possible I can do it
with six people but can I do it with
three how would I incentivize those
people I know I went from like super
dirt sorry clouds to dirt here um but
that's that is how you unlock going from
five locations to 50 locations and then
you start building the machine that
builds the location so then you have
launch teams that fill it up before it
opens you turn it over to management
they keep running it and the big key of
making all of these
work is
that it can't just be based off some
unique acquisition Channel because those
all eventually go away all advertising
platforms will eventually become too
expensive and they will eventually die
because the tension always moves right
and so the only way to become enduring
with your business like if you really
want to not like if you want to sleep
well at night you have to fix the back
end if you know that if you don't sell
any new customers you're still going to
be fine next month and you do that for
three or four more months and you'll
still be fine that's the perfect
business to then go market but like
that's the boring work that no one wants
to do I'm going to end with this one
thing a franchisor of a really popular
uh not really popular they had I think
20 locations uh
franchise came to
me and he's like my
franchise isn't working right and they
had I think six corporate stores 14
franchised and the average store cost
about a million bucks to open and they
made about $150,000 in profit per
year right it's like you might as well
just like invest in a stock and just not
bother right like that's that's what you
have to think with and when I saw that
they were doing I think the average was
like 1.3 in Topline and 150 in bottom
line and I think they were running like
a very small
margin I thought to myself
I think he actually less than 150 point
is shitty
margins he was trying to figure out how
to Market his franchise
better how ridiculous is that right but
the thing is is that like many people
who are in this room are thinking the
exact same
way and so instead what I said was hey
man I actually think your margins below
and I think you have a lot of interest
because that's why I took the call I
knew the brand and I was like I think
you have really good products I think
you just you just have to get the Ops
right to get your Market margins in
check right you've got this menu that
has 500 items on it boil it down to the
top 15 that everyone usually does look
at all the ingredients buy type see if
we can negotiate better deals with
vendors because we're going to
consolidate all of our demand we'll get
more volume etc etc and so what I did
was I said hey we've got 12 months I
want you to spend one month 12 months in
a row to get 1% profit back month one
you get 1% back it's all you have to do
it's my only thing I 1% back and next
month you're going to find another 1%
next month you're going to find another
1% that's all you have to do hey if you
find three three months ahead next month
another 1% and 12 months from now you
would have a business that would be
sellable would be investable and would
have already tripled or whatever was the
profit of that and made it a scalable
Enterprise but he had spent 10 years 10
trying to scale the
franchise when it was the big obvious
thing the sandwich just wasn't that
good the sandwich in the literal sense
was okay for the customer but it was
terrible for the investor so you had to
fix the model and so I think right now a
lot of everyone here as much as
everybody loves to come for leads and
that's great a lot of you guys are just
serving mediocre sandwiches and I think
if you spent a year eating your own
sandwich you would immediately see all
the things that are wrong with it you'd
fix that and then the rest of your life
you'd be able to scale this thing thank
you